hey guys and welcome to another stinking
episode of congratulations
crazy
[Music]
happy new year it's 2
000 wait no not yet right not even yet
yes didn't know when it was going to
come out we're starting too early
but dude that is kind of true i am on my
[ __ ] 2022 [ __ ] but it's still
2021 which is fine and people always act
like you know whoa we had a rough year
and like it's going to stop january 1st
and i'll tell you what i'll tell you
right now it's not
it's not
it's going to be rough if it was rough
december 31st gonna be rough january 1st
but you know what it doesn't matter
because it's all a mentality baby and
life rips and that's why we uh we keep
it real here we keep it real here
congratulations congratulations studios
i got to go medium and sometimes stay
out [ __ ] your boy looks crazy good in
fall colors oh god i'm sorry
but i look crazy good in fall colors i
know
[Music]
it's like maroon and also [ __ ] that's
got that [ __ ] pumpkin pop oh [ __ ] man
i'm i'm sorry but yeah dude go meet him
sometimes stay out crystalia.com go get
we got the hoodie we got the [ __ ]
t-shirt y'all been hitting me up about
the t-shirt and this [ __ ] is fall colors
it's blowing red
we got the i'm sorry strong guys sorry
to break your heart strong guys dude
honestly apologizing a lot in 2022
because i'm gonna be breaking lots of
hearts dude
uh but that's how it goes
you know that's how it goes man
when you uh when you're firing on all
syllables so uh that's it dude it's uh
it's the last episode of 2021
and uh
you know we're kicking it we're having a
good time um i uh i appreciate y'all
listening to we got the patreon.com
crystalia if you want to sign up you get
extra episodes you get all that stuff uh
and all that [ __ ]
um
i
did a
uh we got the disney with chris you sign
up for the second youtube channel with
chris uh more crystalia and i put out
the last video was with chris disneyland
with chris and i went to disneyland and
dude forget it man that's it
i guess
it's it is crazy and i've said i think i
i don't know if i said this in the video
or not i africa cut out but like it is
absolutely crazy how much disneyland is
something i would never want to go to at
all but now that i have a son and a
family i want to go
i want to go i flipped it on its ass
dude i said hey life you think you know
me and i flipped it on its ass
and i went
and i had a great time because i looked
at it through calvin's eyes
i looked at it through my one and almost
two years old son
and it was awesome and dude that guy
mean mugs man he was mean mugging goofy
he was mean mugging pluto he was mean
mug and minnie mickey he saw mickey at
his own house and he was mean mugging
him
kevin was just staring standing there
staring at mickey just mean mugging
mickey the whole time dude and he would
just look back at me like you brought me
here for this [ __ ]
you brought me here for big mice and i
was like bro you're speaking my language
i'm 41.
this is how i do it this is how i come
to places
the boy's obviously my son
and yeah dude we put a video
with chris video and it's got me at
disneyland go check it out if you want
but it's a lot of fun but man i'll tell
you man we got there we stayed there for
three days and it was [ __ ] awesome
dude guess what brought calvin out to
disneyland the night we got there it was
late we brought him out onto the [ __ ]
street into the main drag of disneyland
and as soon as we got there there was
fake snow coming down they put fake snow
dude they do the whole they do the whole
[ __ ] thing there they got the fake
snow the the singing uh the [ __ ]
speakers are blaring and they got like
um
christmas trees and lights broke brought
calvin out guess what
guess what dude and i'm not gonna lie i
cried immediately
[Music]
dude i cried i cried immediately i was
[ __ ] dude your boy sniffles you know
what i [ __ ] legitimately my lips were
[ __ ] puffing in and out that's how
hard i i was i couldn't take it dude too
much emotion for your boy your boy's
been in a lot of therapy so his walls
are down it's super hard to live as a
father and love his son so much with his
walls up
[Music]
so um that's what's up man it is
absolutely beautiful when you're holding
your child
and he's looking up at the fake snow i
mean the dude's never even seen real
snow but it didn't matter disney [ __ ]
did it right
and it was beautiful man
and people were probably like why is
crystalia crying because i had my son
man and my balls are down baby just like
when i told my therapist i was like you
know what i don't like to actually feel
things i don't like to have actual real
connections with people because
that's too real and i feel too hard
and then
the therapist said well you're [ __ ]
now that you have a son because it's
gonna [ __ ] absolutely your love is
going to bloom and it did and now
because my walls are down i'm
experiencing experiencing emotions for
the first time and i cry like i [ __ ]
am a baby
but it's all good and i just want to be
real with you guys dude i would never
keep it fake i keep it real i'm italian
dude what the [ __ ] man
you act like i don't eat [ __ ]
spaghetti all the time with my parents
but i do dude
people say real italians are from
[ __ ] italy dude but we're they're
from [ __ ] new jersey man
how italian is it to be from new jersey
or florida but yeah dude so it's all
good man and uh we went to disneyland
what else did we do let's see what are
the things we did we did we took him to
toontown that [ __ ] was crazy he jumped
in a [ __ ] fake car and we pretended
to drive and he took and he [ __ ] he
was going on with the wheel and then he
was touching the
the honking the horn but it didn't do
anything and he was going pom pom pom
pom so he knows what [ __ ] cars do
dude
my son didn't fall down once i saw so
many kids falling down my son didn't
fall down once dude
my son didn't fall down once he fell
down twice today but not at disneyland
he's got his wits about him when people
are around people trying to stop me
taking hey can i take a picture i'm
holding my son what do i say what do i
say no i'm with my family no i say hey
kristin here take calvin for a second i
stop i take a picture because i'm
practically a politician
right
but disneyland was great man i don't
know how you i don't know how
like i'm just straight up full-blown
cuda when i get there
like i'm like i'm like excited to get
there when i get there i'm with calvin
and i'm just like this is [ __ ]
amazing i don't know how
you
can visit disneyland and not be
a [ __ ] multi-millionaire hell yes
i don't know how you can do it i don't
know how you can go to disneyland and
just be some family
everything is a gillion dollars
everything oh you want fries
cool 42 dollars
oh you want a bubble maker cool 42
dude you oh you want a hat with mickey
ears that's cool but it's 42 dollars
nothing is under 42 i found one thing
where that's 35 bucks
and it was like a keychain dude i swear
to god i can't these the way they
[ __ ] soak the money from these
families it is criminal dude but
mickey's there and he's just like oh
so you're like all right
dude it's practically [ __ ] it's not
even it's barely disneyland it's like
[ __ ] john gotti's running the goddamn
thing hey you know
it's hard to keep the park going you
know it's hard to keep the park
functioning you know we gotta also pay
for security here you know we want
nothing to go wrong while you're inside
the park right that's basically what
[ __ ] mickey's saying
hey you know you wouldn't want to slip
and fall something happened to your head
your [ __ ] dad [ __ ] fall down a
flight of stairs and turn down right
you wouldn't want your mom [ __ ]
falling off the side of space mountain
right
i mean i'm not you know this way
you pitch in a little bit for security
we make sure your mother doesn't fall
off for the [ __ ] matterhorn right
that's basically mickey dude it's
unbelievable a churro is [ __ ] you
know yeah i get it no dents but dude if
you got to go if you're going to if
you're going to uh
uh disneyland you got to go with the no
dense attitude dude you got to go you
got to save the [ __ ] up dude it's
unbelievable man
it's
unbelievable got calvin a balloon it's
twelve dollars he let it go all good
you just gotta charge that [ __ ] to the
disney game right there you gotta charge
it to the game that [ __ ] is game tax
right there
when you buy a 12
balloon at disneyland for your son
that [ __ ] is game tax when it goes away
because he'll let it go
right
it's game tax
um
but yeah we went to toontown let's see
what else we did we did the [ __ ] we
didn't go to the dude when i was there
um because i went there with my mom and
dad too and um they were like telling me
when i was a kid when i was there
because we visited when i was like
however old i was and um
they took me on space mountain i had
[ __ ] never wanted to do roller
coasters at all dude you know me i like
to move around on my own
but like uh they were like do you want
to go my mom and my brother were back in
the hotel and my dad was like you want
to do space mountain like the big boys
and i was like well is it scary he's
like no it shouldn't be scary and plus
you're with me and i'm like okay but i
don't know he's like don't worry about
it you're with me we did space mountain
dude i am on the [ __ ] trail a lot
teacup [ __ ]
i'm on the [ __ ] hunky-dory
you know
like
rides
and my dad's like let's do space
mountain i don't know [ __ ] it's in the
dark we're waiting in line for nine and
a half hours we get a space mountain i'm
like you sure it's okay yeah it's okay
we wreck it
get all the way to the top right
you're sure it's okay yeah right get get
get all the way to the top gets to the
top what happens at the top you [ __ ]
i mean dude it's like you're in an
immediate fighter jet going to the speed
of sound
and you're just going so fast and it's
dark which you would think would be less
scary because you can't see but turns
out it's more [ __ ] scary to a
nine-year-old
i couldn't see and i was moving so fast
i'm scared [ __ ] bars and [ __ ] are
gonna hit my head and i'm gonna get
impaled
right i don't know what's gonna happen
here
and i'm crying so [ __ ] hard the whole
time i remember it i remember this and i
don't remember [ __ ] dude if i close my
eyes i barely remember what i'm wearing
and i'm in this [ __ ]
uh what is it called space mountain
and i stop space mountain
it stops and i'm screaming
and my dad is like oh my god it's okay
are you okay and i said through the
tears you lied to me
and that's my origin story
that's how i became a super villain
right
and then a year later my dad told me
afterwards he was like
he was like
uh one time
uh
mom wasn't home and you were getting
ready for school and you asked me does
this match with this
i was on the top of the stairs and he's
and i said dad he said yep and i said
does this match with this and i held on
shirt and pants and he said yeah and i
said are you sure and he said
yeah when would i uh he said have i ever
lied to you and i said well there was
that one time at space mountain
dude
your boy remembers it when it [ __ ]
matters
[Music]
two because i brought it back
there was that one time at space
mountain dude kids never forget i know
you know that's a funny joke now but i
never want to [ __ ] be that way to
calvin not that my dad [ __ ] up he
didn't [ __ ] up he's a good he's a good
you know he's a good guy sometimes i
wish he would confront more [ __ ] more
more
he used to confront so many people when
we were
but when we were we would like go on
vacation
i would just and now i'm this guy i i
used to be like dad don't be mean to the
guys and he wasn't being mean now i know
as a 41 year old and an adult in my
profession that does well in my
profession when somebody doesn't do
their job i get a little bit and i got
to work on it too because i know not
everybody's doing the job that they want
to do i know that but when somebody like
[ __ ] up their job royally
i'm just like well i work i do you know
i always try so hard white but if they
[ __ ] up the rooms at the hotels dude my
dad would just be like cool i'm gonna go
talk to the guy and my mom oh bill bill
and then i would be like
that
and i'd be like [ __ ] 15. dad did that
don't can you be nice to the guy he just
he probably got a family you know you
know what i mean what if he's poor i
would just say that like as a as a
[ __ ] 11 year old and he's like yeah
but you know you pay a lot of money for
these [ __ ] rooms and and he got me
put me next to the [ __ ] air
conditioning and this [ __ ] two we're
on the second floor i asked for the
ninth floor or whatever the [ __ ]
and he's like that don't do that [ __ ]
but now i get it dude
and now i get it
and then my dad doesn't do it and i do
it and i do do it and calvin if he does
the same thing to me dude if i grow up
if calvin grows up and he does the same
thing to me boy that that is going to be
a [ __ ] crazy inception moment that's
for sure
so what else did we do at disneyland we
um my son loved turning the lights on
and off in the hotel room that's kind of
one of his things
um didn't even [ __ ] in the park at all
like the guy's just gangster he's just
like oh [ __ ] later
i [ __ ] at the hotel room when it's
convenient for everyone i don't want to
walk around shitty butt
just killing it would come home to the
hotel room look at me and just go
and i'm like jesus you really got good
with that time he's like just waiting
for you dad
don't wanna [ __ ] near donald
um
so yeah dude
there's a lady online from the [ __ ]
what's the where is she from the one
that's selling her uh bottled farts
from the uh 90 day fiance yeah dude
there's a lady from 90 day fiance this
is the most too let me just wrap 2021 up
with this there's a lady from 90 today
fiance that's selling her own bottled
farts and i mean just like that whole
sentence dude
she sells her bottled farts dude and
it's such a crock of [ __ ] no pun
intended but like dude you can't say
farts i got the [ __ ] biggest argument
about this
they were like can you
can you the people i was with were like
can you
bottle farts and will they smell in the
[ __ ] bot and everyone was like yeah
it'll stay smelling if you just leave it
tight sealed and it's like dude no it
won't
no it won't when you fart in a bottle
and then you cap it whenever you open it
up
it's not going to be smelly period
if you're paying for this [ __ ] chick
from 90 day fiance's farts
you're getting nothing you're getting an
empty bottle and everyone is so [ __ ]
they think that they're so like
everyone's such a cuda this is pinnacle
barracuda [ __ ] dude
where you just you want to be a part of
the funk man you see that [ __ ] and
you're like oh yeah and then you you
literally believe that you're smelling
it i do not believe a scientist can tell
me this [ __ ] could be possible i do not
believe you can actually smell farts
from a bottle if it's been carried
across state
there's just no [ __ ] way
and kristen was like well you know i
mean technically farts are little pieces
of [ __ ] and i'm just like you don't know
about pieces of [ __ ] my son just handed
me one
i mean there's just no [ __ ] way
i don't care if a [ __ ] tick tock
doctor is like well actually it's pellet
pizza and you could and if i no no no
how how much i mean dude to sell farts
it's also like i love how like this
chick on 90 day fiance is like acting
like it's not a sexual thing
like
any
girl that is selling anything
actually unless it's like from a company
and sexual to the guy you know
hey guys
anytime a girl starts a thing like that
the guy thinks it's sexual
hey guys i just i've been
so i've been living in this sweater and
i'm just gonna ah
[Music]
it's sexual to a guy
you know not just panties i don't get
that kink you know
guys want panties and socks
but it's like some chicks are out there
like should i just sell feed pics i mean
it's not
it's not the it's not like it's my [ __ ]
or tits
it's sexual to the guy
people hit kristen up for feet picks
so far she stayed true to me
but times get hard we might sell them
feet picks
um
brother used to actually now that i
think about there used to be a guy that
used to comment on my thing that every
time my feet were seen you'd be like man
i love your feet
it's always sexual guys can make
anything sexual though for real like
straight up like there's kinks for good
oh you go on going pointless kings for
everything
but i don't know
what was i talking about to selling the
farts dude why did they but they
interviewed her they were like why do
you why do you why do you think people
buy your farts and she was like because
i think i'm a good person oh dude that's
what she said though
that's what you said because i'm a good
person
imagine thinking someone bought your
farts
because you give to charity
imagine walking in the living room and
just somebody huh and someone goes ill
and you say i'm a good person it's fine
i'm charitable
what sorry i'm charitable
enjoy it
i give to unicef
you know what i mean
i feed the homeless
you're you're welcome dude that's so
gross how [ __ ] stupid can you be
she's got to be putting one on us man
just also dude just [ __ ] in it
you know you're gonna [ __ ] putin it
like a [ __ ] [ __ ] in it and then
then i'll buy it
because it's embarrassing for both of us
a fart is nothing you know by the time i
get it it's nothing
you know you sell me a fart and you ship
it to me by the time i get it it's
nothing [ __ ] in it so we can both be
embarrassed and i get to keep
that of yours hey guys got the 90 day
fiance girl [ __ ]
i'll bring it to my shows i'll do a
[ __ ] whole bit about it i'll be a
prop comic with your [ __ ]
so gross dude
um
[Music]
what's up with this [ __ ] uh
liver king guy dude like just how about
this man you know the liver king guy the
guy who's like literally looks like a
ninja turtle but he's not green like
he's so jacked he's on tick tock or
instagram like guy just relax
just chill for a little bit
why why are you so
so strong you know what i'm talking
about first of all you're 4-3
nobody is that jacked that's not like
even the rock would look at this guy and
be like why do you look like [ __ ]
uh bebop and rocksteady got it right
this time couldn't get it last episode
but the guy's so jacked
he looks like i mean [ __ ] dude
he's so jacked he looks like a beetle
and he's got a huge beard
and he eats [ __ ] bone marrow hey guy
give it a rest
it's weird to be one of those big jacked
muscular dudes and absolutely have no
use for it you know what i mean like
you're just your uses looking in the
mirror and going nice
what's your use dude you're not climbing
you're not go you're not [ __ ]
like what it and it's and you're not in
a competition like bodybuilding okay but
also you're not in the composite
condition you're just outside and then
on tick-tock the guy [ __ ] is like
yeah i got my bone right here got my
bones right here like what this isn't a
meal man
bones
he's just like yeah here's here's here's
here let's click on this
this is him eating
here we go this is him eating we got a
protein shake okay protein
where's my liver here's my liver okay
dude first of all
where's my liver you know
hey guy eat a cheeseburger
where's my liver here's my liver also
always know where your liver is
the you couldn't possibly hand me a can
of liver
and i wouldn't know where it is in my
house
hey chris where'd you put that right
here that's where i'm i'm [ __ ] right
there with you hey chris where'd you put
that it's right here
where's i put it over there near the
[ __ ] shelf
got three or four ounces of liver in
here of course ounces we have some bone
marrow a couple of pieces of femur bone
how do you chew it we have a liver king
concoction always disgusting some grass
in the sugar
dude concoction
you know
this is the liver every so far
everything has been liver
you know here we got the liver here
where's my liver here's my liver three
ounces of liver we've got a liver
concoction we've got bones from a liver
cow
you know how we do it you know the drill
no no no dude you know how we do it dude
i love the [ __ ] you know how we do it
guys
only guys who are telling you
how they're doing it
say you know how we do it and it's like
yeah because you just got done telling
me liver king
some homemade pork rinds
ah
so much meat
a couple pieces of avocado because
that's all their queen would spare for
me and four cheeseburgers a little bit
of onion
we have some garnishes we got some
fermented ketchup from the farm some
maple syrup in case we need to slather
some more calories on and a couple of
fermented pickles here
for dinner today
and then he [ __ ] shaves the bones on
the burgers and eats it
like it's salt like what are you doing
dude hey guy although he looks like he's
[ __ ] killing it dude i mean the guy's
getting like nice houses and [ __ ] but
hey dude
i'll say it you look awful
hey i'll say why does nobody tell
jacked guys hey guy
you look
awful
dude like i was watching a podcast i
think rogan and somebody else and they
were like yeah chicks say they don't
like muscular guys they're lying dude no
what
no they're they're not lying and and
here's the [ __ ] haters be like oh
christopher's jealous well i work out
your boy keeps it beefy i'm breaking
strong guys hearts all across the
country
well into the uk
i got [ __ ] in australia with a
[ __ ] severed heart because i'm doing
20 chin-ups in a row
19.
but it's like dude so don't come at me i
don't want to look
like a turtle
it's so ridiculous how these
[ __ ] look they look awful
dude and and nobody will
say it i guess
it's crazy
that people
it's crazy that when big ass muscular
dudes walk into places that people don't
audibly go ew
or at least
whoa
i'm gonna do that now from now on i'm
gonna be if i'm in target and a [ __ ]
huge dude with like one of those scoopy
tank tops where we could see their
[ __ ] tits
some dude walks in with some really
short red shorts and a scoopy tank top
to expose nipples i'm just gonna go whoa
hey dude you finished working out
congratulations
you going again tomorrow why
well because i got all this liver i got
to eat
hey man this liver isn't going to eat it
eat itself here's another video one fire
just sent it to me
wow
liver king here our early ancestors
prized seafood so much so that even when
tribes were at war with one another
those that were landlocked would trade
with the enemy to procure the stuff
really [ __ ] went downhill when he
said stuff you know
was so well said until he said stuff
let's say it again let's see it again
to procure the stuff
liver king here our early ancestors
prized seafood so much so that even when
tribes were at war with one another
those that were landlocked would trade
with the enemy to procure the stuff
went downhill dude the guys on so many
steroids why are we i don't understand i
eat seafood once a week with my tribe
every wednesday skin on bone and
sardines and if you can't do that you
can do what a bear does go straight for
the source and get the eggs
what
no the
oh no this guy's gonna die so early he's
they're scared
the [ __ ] can he first of all he has a
helper he holds the trout up or whatever
the [ __ ] it is
and and the person comes in and starts
squeezing it and and out of the fish's
[ __ ] is just plopping eggs into his
[ __ ] beard and he's opening his mouth
while the helper's squeezing it
this is a dead fish you know and the
guy's just going like this a few [ __ ]
eggs fall out of the fish's [ __ ] and
then he goes more
hey guy
this is like the first
guy
that ever existed only somehow he's in
2021.
guaranteed guarantees this more again i
knew it i knew it dude yes dude i know
people
more he keeps saying more
the fish is [ __ ] in his mouth
i was going to throw up so hard it was
going to throw up so hard
that has all the goodness
passed out right after this and the sea
life and that's how you do it like a
bear little king out
threw up passed out like [ __ ] wood
like when when jake paul hit woodley
[ __ ] passed out like that with his
arms down after that
i mean who's helping him you know
the liver queen bro this is so gross
hey guys
god guys are so weird
tribes anytime somebody's like you know
what's unbelievable the guy has no
tattoos
it's unbelievable
it's so weird that people are
like when guys are always talking about
like my tribe and [ __ ] it's like
no dude you work in an office building
do you know what i'm talking about
this is just i mean i know you don't
wear a shirt a lot liver king but like
guys you know it guys who were in like f
that were in frats are like yeah man my
tribe me and my kids my tribe
are like [ __ ] the rock says it a lot
like dude
god damn i'm so sick of actors acting
like acting is hard too like for real
like i've i've like dude i saw i
followed this one actor and he was just
like hey man it's six on his story was
like it's six a.m
and i just [ __ ]
i'm up i'm up all year while you're
sleeping get grinded and he's just like
was like going over
sides like dude
first of all what everyone wakes up at 6
00 a.m
i mean i don't except for comedians and
babies
everyone wakes up at six to go to work
even moms wake up at six because their
kids are waking up at six and this guy's
like dude the grind never stops 6am
with a highlighter
oh yeah really the grind never stops
with a yellow highlighter
dude it's hilarious acting isn't
[ __ ] hard okay it's not hard i get it
the rock's schedule is hard but what the
rock is actually doing it's not
hard it's not hard
i was in that [ __ ] movie army of the
dead it's not hard i was out there was
hotty [ __ ] in albuquerque albuquerque
sucks
i had to wait around a lot
it was hard to take off my [ __ ]
jumpsuit because i had to piss but it's
not hard to be like
here they come
this is what acting is
unless you're [ __ ] christian bale by
the way and i don't mean the diet [ __ ]
christian bale does some weird hard
acting and uh the guy who played abe
lincoln daniel day lewis hard acting but
also
if you're doing that you're probably a
huge [ __ ]
nah dude i'm abe lincoln actually even
when the camera isn't running oh really
i gotta [ __ ] change my life now okay
okay 16th president
it's just not hard
and like
what was i talking about something about
[ __ ] goddamn i don't even remember
but like it's just like
i don't know he was eating [ __ ]
fish [ __ ] and now i'm [ __ ] talking
about how acting isn't hard but whatever
it's just like actors dude the [ __ ]
oscars i talked about it when the oscars
have every year when the oscars happen
it's just like it's so just okay dude
all right all right you said some
[ __ ] lines that's it i got a friend
in vancouver right now doing a movie and
it's so easy for him he's just chilling
at 11 a.m he's just chilling in the
trailer waiting to get called to come in
and say well this looks a little
suspicious nine times and then eat some
[ __ ] bagels at craft service
don't let these [ __ ] actors say oh
yeah it's grueling in the [ __ ] dude
it's not man [ __ ] all that [ __ ]
you know how many times a career
somebody gets to play in a movie like
manchester by the sea [ __ ] once
it's not hard
the only one doing hardship is hugh
jackman that's because he dances in
every goddamn movie and figures out a
way to sing
um
but yeah dude and the liver king's name
is brian johnson
so [ __ ] basic
i gotta send him some sorry strong guys
merch
um i want to actually talk about this
guy matt rife who's a comedian that has
a uh um
a special on youtube i love this dude
he's funny he's one of the [ __ ]
hardest workers and he's a great
stand-up uh uh and he's and he's got his
special for free on youtube so type in
matt rife m-a-t-t-r-i-f-e
and watch his special he's a great guy
and uh he's uh you know it'd be cool to
get his clicks up there because uh i
[ __ ] i like to do it so check that
out if you can that's me co signing um i
saw the [ __ ] jake paul fight i really
kind of only saw that sixth round which
was unbelievable dude i've talked about
this before but jake paul uh smash and
tyrone what do they do let me tell you
something you don't [ __ ] with somebody
who's an underdog and jake paul has
lived to be the underdog everybody was
making fun of this [ __ ] everyone
hated this dude well if if so if you're
somebody who people hate
and you train that's a deadly weapon
that's it
all the boxers come out of the [ __ ]
most hardcore ghettos jake paul is in
the mental ghetto because everyone hates
this [ __ ] he's in the ghetto of
shame he's in the shame ghetto because
everyone [ __ ] can't stand this
[ __ ] and he flipped it on him by
training he flipped it on him and now
he's beating the [ __ ] out of
[ __ ] real fighters
yeah it's not grappling okay tyrone
woodley is a rat as a grappler okay but
he knocked him out cold he slumped him
he goes like this yo it's past midnight
go to sleep and the guy fell down chin
first
now you never know but this these by if
you're not a boxer you've got to stop
dude but they're not going to because
they're making 70 million dollars right
and i'm so sick of everyone saying oh
it's rigged dude how about this even if
it is who [ __ ] cares it's a youtuber
proof the tyrone woodley jake paul fight
was rigged okay
now what
can i watch something else who gives a
[ __ ]
you know it's not like it's [ __ ]
spinx and tyson who cares also who even
cares if that's i don't care do it
but it's so weird that people are like
oh oh yeah another rigged fight another
it's like d okay so what they say hey
tyrone woodley you could get [ __ ]
this many millions of dollars if you
just take a hit all right they're not
gonna stop dude it's better if it's
better for showtime if jake paul [ __ ]
becomes a big boxing star which he
already is practically
but it's uh it's it's uh you know they
need a star and they need another star
canelo how long is he gonna go
you know
that's hbo but like uh tyson fury how
long is he gonna go
you need a star and yeah it's gonna be
that [ __ ] lit
i don't know man i don't know
all i'm saying is
these guys are all going to be [ __ ]
brain dead in like like when they're 50
they're all going to be just like brain
i mean dude you're taking shots to the
dome even jake paul said the other day
he was like i already have suffered from
memory loss
i love every time i go to the doctor i
tell him something he's like well yeah
no that's just what happens like with
like i i go to the doctor last time i
went to doctor i was like yeah man i
forget a lot more than i usually do than
i used to and he's like well how old are
you i'm like 41. oh yeah no that's just
what happens oh okay
is it the gabapentin no it's just
probably you're getting older oh okay
last time i asked him i was like i was
like hey i'm tired of [ __ ] what's up i'm
like way more tired than i used to be
he's like how old are you i'm like 35
and he said oh yeah no that's just kind
of what happens i said so i'm just gonna
be tired all the time now am i not
getting enough iron he's like no you're
just 35 you're just tired now dude what
else happens that's what i want to know
i'm 41 what else happens i guess the
vision goes next early 40s your vision
is supposed to go hardcore right like
you're not supposed to look at things
closely
you got to hold them out you got to
start doing the thing where you're
holding them out like you're in a
[ __ ] christmas carol just staring at
[ __ ]
manuscripts with the burnt fringes oh
yes yes
like that's i guess what happens next
i'm gonna go to the doctor hey man i
can't see stuff it's closer yeah no
that's just what happens
what else
this [ __ ] is like when you found that
[ __ ] santa the tooth fairy and the
[ __ ] green goblin weren't real
i was like oh dude why didn't you just
tell me when i was younger dude i didn't
know you start forgetting [ __ ] when
you're 41.
no yeah that's just what happens can i
take anything no no not anything with no
side effects okay
okay i guess um
boxing just seems like such a bad idea
dude
if boxing if boxing is boxing
and
football well also the ufc started in
1999 now it wouldn't start though maybe
it would dude money talks i don't know
liver king you know
king
go to chrisalia.com and get your merch
get your chrysalia.com he's also on
cameo he goes out there he's been having
fun he's been having a lot more fun than
he thought he would on cameo go to cameo
dot com slash crystallia for all your
holiday greetings and birthdays and
he'll just shout you out or she really
really really will give you the biz
cameo
um
what's this michael kane
merry christmas tweet what was it again
i [ __ ] wrote this down i forget
you dropped it
he's dropping it
he's dropping it he's dropping it it's
not on it yet but he's dropping it
nope and one fire said whoops and of
course one fire
it was seven days ago i'll just pull it
up right here here it is and it's not
showing me because i'm not logged in i
haven't been on here we go wow dude the
guy just shows a picture oh dude this is
on michael king continues to be the best
person on the internet it's unreal
dude he just put happy xmas and it's his
headshot also
wow is there anything more old guy than
that
happy by the way
sometimes i say happy christmas but
whenever i do i think about it
it's so british right is that a british
thing
what's up with that dude just say mary
also no you know what [ __ ] that say
happy why are we why did we change it to
mary anyway what is this [ __ ] 1812
yes his merry because his belly's full
imagine how are you ah mary
in [ __ ] august
i'm mary
also dude he put it
up
december 13th
he probably is like oh i don't know how
long i have left i definitely want to
i am 984 years old
might as well just be like do you want
to put the tweet out now i'll do it
dude michael caine is still in so many
[ __ ] movies dude hey michael kane
quit
hey michael kane
dude he's like the liver king of acting
you just want to be like another [ __ ]
movie
michael kane dude i'll do it that's the
thing i don't get see this is the thing
the whole i used to think my career was
the most important thing in my life and
it's just not i wonder how michael caine
is in a as a real person
like nobody works that much
and is not i that's just i don't know
man
dude how easy is it to act in the roles
that michael caine does too he's always
just like oh excuse me
you know well
he's always like that and [ __ ]
the one good acting the one hard acting
he did was in the dark knight when he
was just like i've always loved you or
whatever the [ __ ] he says to christian
bale
and christian bell was [ __ ]
god
i'll tell you right now i'm calling
christian bell's gonna die so early
cause of all of his weight fluctuation
oh good we'd like to keep it real i'm
italian we keeps it real like italians
files done dude [ __ ] one fire's
stomach just spoke so loud it was
unbelievable dude it went err
honestly it was cheesy oh
it's not cute
sensation it wasn't queued up and i'm
pissed great
all good cheesecake
[Laughter]
sensational
so weird
i don't that's this is the thing like
when they asked so
oh wait they said what's your favorite
thing and he said cheesecake was that
what it was
yeah now you don't miss me with them
[ __ ] questions dude anybody ever does
those questions with me again miss me
with that [ __ ] for real i don't do fun
[ __ ] questions like that ah so
crystalia what what are you mad dude
miss me with those [ __ ] for
real
all right let's do some uh
um uh
chris christmas and years end
um
what do you call a misconnection oh no
ah yeah let's do that right now
wow
why are these always so foreign
like
why isn't it just like
here it is miss my bright beachy girly
friend
we used to hang out at santa monica and
talk all night
beach coffee houses and restaurants we
closed them all
it didn't matter what we talked about
you're always so smart and well read
please come back to me or send me a
friend wow that dude
90 of these are
so like longing for the specific love
and then at the
very end just actually longing for any
love
that's the [ __ ] so telling about
people who do this
you know they just want any kind of
[ __ ] connection
right
it's like oh man i missed you so much
you were the guy who [ __ ] i met at
subway we're both of the same sandwich
and we had this [ __ ] beautiful long
conversation and we talked outside until
the sun went down and it was along the
pch god i miss it so much reach out if
it's you i think your name is greg also
anyone hit me up
also if you have a [ __ ] or [ __ ] or legs
or arms doesn't matter just say what up
they're all like that at the end
morning here's a saw each other shopping
west hollywood morning i was with my
husband and you ran into me accidentally
but asked if i want black meat i'm
interested let's talk
i mean how did someone who is so obvious
in real life how did it not work out
already
how do you need to get to the internet
hey
nobody's shy in this situation
imagine somebody's got the balls to say
hey
do you do you want black meat
and you have the [ __ ]
want
for black meat
so enough to [ __ ]
write about it and think about it and
put it on the internet
you already did all the hard work
how are you running to the [ __ ] miss
connections anonymously when the hard
work is done
it's like building a hotel and then
being like
uh [ __ ] you know what dude we gotta
finish those blueprints hey
you don't have people stay in you
you know
here's another one looking for a lady to
eat out
lady and eat out
are so diametrically opposed
like so
like classy but also crassy [ __ ] by the
end
hello i'm looking for a lady to eat out
ride offered gets way worse
ride offered from l-a-o-c-l-b
wow
so [ __ ] directional right now you
come over to me i come over to you or we
can do it in my car single white guy is
here in good shape ryde offered from
laoc
uh
wow
like not gonna get anyone
here we go oh this is a good one
bear pitcher needs twink receiver
mixing up sports
looking for a twink
mound to pitch my balls to
dad died early
looking for a twink mound
to pitch my balls to
wow
wow this one's so vague like just tweet
it right here christmas chick and
snowflakes los angeles any cool guy
doing anything cool this weekend
hey send out a mass text
hey text your friends hey tweet it hey
put up a facebook message or uh what do
you call it
here's another one kimmy griffin which
wow nobody really says names oh this is
a call kimmy griffin whittier college
1970s whittier california kimmy griffin
was a pretty african-american woman who
attended whittier college in the 1970s
this guy know how to use facebook she
was a devout christian and took at least
one religion class and attended a bible
study called rejoice in jesus worst
class iirc she had worked with animals
and with a veterinarian i believe she
was a bit short and also wore eyeglasses
how do you remember all this [ __ ] but
not know if she was short or not
does anyone have any knowledge of where
she is today i would like to touch bases
with her before i die
oh wow
this is michael kane
dude i would like to touch bases first
of all
whether before i die
so morbid for no reason like
like anyone's gonna read this and be
like oh [ __ ] okay well i was gonna i was
gonna
save this till tomorrow but
posted about 17 hours ago get on it if
you know kimmy griffin also
does the guy know how to use
anything
any google facebook instagram just type
in kimmy griffin
wow unbelievable
um
all right what else can i talk about
that was all i had but there's a [ __ ]
i should do one more thing
[ __ ] i'm sweaty as [ __ ]
oh yeah okay you know what let me slip
into something a little more comfortable
there that's much better um i feel way
better go meet him and sometimes stay
out wow get the hoodie now it's [ __ ]
legit dude that was legitness
we had somebody stand with him we had a
family staying with him we had a friend
staying with us
um
this past week we went to disneyland
with him but we also had him staying in
our extra one of our extra rooms one of
our extra rooms with a [ __ ]
um and uh
he's a chef dude and he cooks man
and it's so awesome to be a good cook
because it's so far from something that
i would ever do i have never i've cooked
spaghetti once
quesadillas a few times
eggs are plenty
and that's
it
right anything with ingredients or
anything like that when i was a kid i i
would like i didn't like stuff wow this
is actually i forgot about this when i
was a kid i didn't like like if there
was like a loaf or a [ __ ] cake or a
or a bread and it had like stuff in it
that you could see
i would say to my mom like i would say
to my mom i would say to my mama mom i
don't like this kind and she's like how
do you know you didn't try it and i'd
say because it because
of all the it has all it has ingredients
in it
and she was like what are you talking
about and i was like you see all these
ingredients and she was like everything
has [ __ ] ingredients in it and i'm
like no but you could see it she thought
she i thought that things you saw like
if you could see like diced up walnuts
in bread that was that was what
ingredients were that's how it should be
and um so there was anything with
ingredients in it though more than like
three ingredients dude i'm out this guy
was here he's a chef and he's got like
five restaurants and he [ __ ] cooked
to oblivion dude and this [ __ ] was so
good man this [ __ ] was so [ __ ] good
it was so good
um salt and smoke is what he owns in st
louis and you guys got to go check it
out but it's so it's it's he's such a
good cook and it's so like
uh it's like let me be the guy though
you know it's my house you know it's
like
ah
everyone's like this is so good and i
got to be like all right well this isn't
really the place to do stand-up but i i
got my own [ __ ] going
they're like yeah but how good is his
steak but i'm like yeah but like okay
but like after you're done with it you
[ __ ] it out and like it's over
and you gotta clean dishes but if you
just come and [ __ ] watch me yell into
a microphone you'll laugh and can leave
without having to clean up though
but dude good cooks are [ __ ] they
keep them panties dropped dude even mine
for real
so good man these guys who just cook it
up man forget it guy fieri i ate his
food once pretty good dude i mean not
pretty good very good and i it's just
like god damn man these [ __ ]
and then you go to restaurants and some
of this [ __ ] is so bad and it's just
like
a good cook huh he loved it do we even
cleaned up afterwards like this guy's
trying to make me [ __ ] move like dude
and then that's the thing too if you're
with a cook
if you if you're a guy and you don't
cook and then a cook comes over and
cooks then you know like your girl is
always like
they're gonna have that thing like
kristen didn't even say it but she's i
know she's thinking like
you know you know
huh okay or whatever the [ __ ] and i'm
like yeah but
i got my own [ __ ] alright you know
i just want to be like all right i
bought this
house like my insecurities start to come
out yeah he can make a pork loin but
you know i
he's probably not that good on stage is
all i'm saying
does he have a podcast
oh he does okay
my god dude
it's an art
calvin doesn't need [ __ ] and even he
liked it
my mom and my dad reading it dude it's
the first meal i ever didn't put salt on
that's how crazy it is so you gotta go
to salt and smoke
uh in st louis but it was so good dude i
don't know i don't know man i mean it's
like i don't cook all right and and like
kristen's gonna have to be happy with
that okay
i've even talked to her about it
i think she's probably okay with it
i guess he left and it's like i gotta be
extra hilarious or something
she likes me for me anyway so [ __ ] off
i forgot about this
good vibes i want to do a segment called
good vibes and here it is
dwayne wade
who you know how he spells his name
wrong that's not what this is about
but uh he spells it d-w-y-a-n-e
he spells it wrong but that's how you
spell it i guess
he
he said my wife and i our whole job is
to provide to protect to love to
facilitate it's not to say you're gonna
be this and you're gonna do that it's to
find out who our children are find out
their likes and their dislikes and try
to help them through life find
themselves it's not about us you know
what i mean it's not about us really
drove it home at the end there i love it
i love it man
you know it's not the [ __ ] 50s
anymore
right
where the kids just like but i want to
play ball
or but i want to dance or whatever the
[ __ ]
it's cool if you're [ __ ] like that's
the thing man being a kid or being a
having a kid rather like thinking about
calvin and like if he grew up and if he
was like
you know sure it's harder to come out of
the closet and live a life as a gay
person because it's like because of
society and all the norms and [ __ ] i
mean not everywhere is los angeles where
they're just [ __ ] having parades
every three weeks but like
and super accepted but like
if if my son or or daughter or whoever i
had grew up now that i have one like if
they grew up to be
gay
it's like i can't imagine just
fully supporting and loving the [ __ ] out
of them
for that
like i just don't get it i don't get it
it's not 1950s anymore
you know people give him [ __ ] because i
think his son or his daughter is trans
one of them i don't know i don't really
know his whole family life but um
props to dwayne uh wade even though you
didn't spell your [ __ ] first name
right um so that's it dude uh that's the
good vibe segment and you guys have been
great thank you so much for [ __ ]
closing this year out
2021 we got go on go ahead and uh hit
that merch chris leah.com hit the like
button go ahead and make friends in
those comments and uh keep the algorithm
going keep the algorithm going keep it
pumping for congratulations dude cause
your boy can't fart on all syllables if
you ain't watching dude i will quit
but um i love you guys
patreon.comcrystalia
and uh
you know we get closer and closer to
[ __ ] building that log cabin and
sharing ideas
thanks guys oh also i forgot one more
thing um i'm doing my my uh
my my weekend in oxnard california at
the improv
uh at the uh oxnard improv in california
it's gonna be crystallia and friends you
can get tickets now on my website
crystallia.com
and uh it will sell out so uh come on
over and see uh me in oxnard california
and see me and my friends do some stand
up
crystalia.com hey guys that's the
episode for today on youtube if you want
to catch the rest of the episode if you
want to catch the uncut episode with no
commercials no ads no nothing uh for six
dollars a month you can go on
patreon.com
you get an extra episode a month you get
all the backlog of all the extra
episodes that have been not seen by the
regular uh public on youtube and other
segments i do uh other uh outtakes i
i've done like with the brian callum
video i did um there's uh more footage
and [ __ ] so uh going over to
patreon.comcrystalia and check it all
out thanks guys
[Laughter]
[Music]
congratulations
check check one check one check
challenge sound sound check one
[Music]